hi guys guess who I'm playing yes I know
this has been done again and again and
again but I was lucky enough to get this
bought for me for my birthday from DX
Dutch so thank you I asked you guys if
you wanted to see me play this and you
said yes she bought me season 2 so I'm
gonna play all of them you can let me
know if you want me to carry on I am a
very emotional person
so this could be quite fun to watch
previously on The Walking Dead
what's your name I'm 99 we've been all
by yourself through this I know who you
are and I know you might kill I hope you
know what you're doing with her Molly
said Crawford is the only place left in
Savannah that still has people it means
it must be where my mom and dad her time
I think it'd be safer for you to stay
here with Olli
Clementine Clementine oh I know how to
be a dad you know she wouldn't be
exposed to what she has been with you we
I saw my parents
oh that's remains what do you think
serious I am we are not doing that why
not because what are they doing
come on Krista what's wrong with though
mean we're not calling our baby or Meade
none of you is enough
Clementine a little help here no oh me
junior no suicide put the boats deadlock
yeah well my vote counts for two that's
not fair
how are you going into labor soon no
then don't talk to me about fair
you're not taking this seriously I take
everything seriously especially the low
meets future keep talking funny that you
shorty tonight remember that time in
Barstow Vegas weekend why don't you get
cleaned up at the girls room clean I
hope the sink works in there I wouldn't
count on it
just be careful and make sure to keep
track of your things we'll be right next
door okay
see I just wouldn't that a little girl
walking into toilet on her own well when
that doesn't be a polka latex going on
why would you do that
happy bless you babe it was stupid okay
Oh gross
what's that Oh teddy
no no one in there oh it's supposed to
stay as well because I did play this on
my xbox cleaned up okay but so I did
play this on my xbox but because I
didn't play it on Steam none of my
choices got saved so and forgetting all
that but those weren't my choices I
don't think I would have make them shoot
me to be honest and I wouldn't have
killed anyone but yeah we'll carry on
just say those weren't my choices don't
yell at me
do the tops even work please have water
you thought Buffett figures
better I was really back on a screen
did you do to do far too calm
was it this one no this one
there it is
you how she didn't put the logo I
thought were made for standing outside
though I thought he was guarding her see
no one cares of it Clementine
she's such shots someone before its time
Elena's not a zombie I see you but that
might this is out of this month someone
out now you are you none of your
business
you're stupid she's only you don't girl
get out here - no girl - even humans
turn in human you got anything on you
come on let's see I ain't gonna ask
again you don't have to do this it's me
you've got to be mean to keep going out
here I'm not yeah she's not your gun I'm
serious
what else you got that's it don't lie to
me
give me what you got
I'm not screwing around come on just
walk away
whatever whatever
give me that hat no where'd you get it
I'm asking you a question
my dad gave it to me just give it to me
[ __ ] absolute [ __ ] junk junk junk look
at all this junk [ __ ] [ __ ] and more [ __ ]
won't leave mentioned only gonna get
[ __ ] but like the last people I mean
they had all kinds of issues come on
that was a good catch
be just a little fish you're gonna cry
little fish fish this your daddy put a
bozo
I'm not gonna lie I paid I've seen the
first three - sorry I need to need to I
didn't mean to I didn't mean
Oh me didn't you hear me homie
it's just the worst way to like begin
something look at what I watch got
dinner that was just as bad
Crysta talk to me
no baby
this will never work
look at this it's pathetic the woods do
wet to burn
more smoke than flame
at this rate we'll be eating this for
breakfast it's okay I can wait all we do
is wait and for what
you should be doing this not me tending
a fire so you can cook and stay warm
it's something you have to be able to do
Clementine otherwise
well needs said that I know what Amin
said I'm so mean why don't say that I uh
I should move to that oh well we're
freezing you think this is bad wait till
we get up to Wellington then talk to me
about coal if we make it we still have a
couple hard months ahead of us this rain
will turn to sleet then ice then snow it
won't be easy
it's safe there safer than here because
he toy so they say we just need to keep
moving north hi miss Lee I'm sure you do
I'm asleep I'm gonna go look for more
would you just keep the fire lit
nicely
so for those of you who don't know Lee
was pretty much a father figure he found
out hiding up a tree house and to go in
and he's the one that she shot because
he was a zombie so it wasn't really her
fault
he was just a zombie stuff
Oh left push Mouse yeah
put on the piggy
better but still not enough the flames
are too low
that pays I've never cooked it's not Pig
okay it's a rabbit now okay it's just
stupid
this won't burn that'll burn this might
burn everyone likes to burn of the
things burn not the firmly why would you
do that I've been in love yeah why don't
you do any the otherwise
where's the rest of your group I'm by
myself
[ __ ] lyin cut the [ __ ] lady it's
distracting obviously do it
over here now
I just don't understand that some of you
book an evening right around
over here
yes
remember that were like
Oh
No
no the girl by Jensen
my arms get away though my arm
Oh God which one you
she is so brave right there with your
mouth numb
beautiful music oh she's in pitiful
it's so cute
not the way she was she's not working
faster than that seriously kids camp
oh that's so good sorry
I should not love staff
Krista Cree there hmm
I doubt she is there
ooh nice oh nice
I don't know how she does it like I
thought I was a heart only doesn't be a
public so I'd be freaking out what it's
not saying beware your surroundings
black bass careful careful
you just so lost
a preparing fighting stance
nah it's okay boy that's okay justic pet
the dog okay
no don't like that got it the more dogs
like time what's he doing hey what'd you
find boy where are you going wait up
hello
looks pretty run over but you never know
let's look around for some food
hmm
but let's find the food okay
is that the dogs family looks like they
were a happy family ones I hope they
love behind some
in a chance think anyone's been sleeping
in here
I can't tell something that don't go be
able to tell you maybe we'd better not
wait around to find out
good idea with it oh whoa throw the dog
hey want to play
yes want to play catch ok forget back
some obedience no dog does that no dog
does that good boy good boy
get it again
we want to go Jackie nope
a stuff
it's not much of a tense anymore I bet
scavengers torn apart the same ones
though hunting you down
oh hey boy what's the matter
you have to be quiet
what Oh what's in here is it cool oh you
know look at the caller just ignore it
don't bark enough laughing good in there
open it open it I am so sick of that
smell what is it oh hello talk to the
hidden soul doggie it's just a dead man
it's okay it's okay he's dead very well
done
look go and see the bite who looks like
he tried to have got it out
it's okay
we're smart he's not are smarter than
all of them so freaky I wouldn't know
Hey
it's okay boy he can't hurt us I think
he had himself tied up or did someone
force him to do this I'm gonna hope they
the first one say he was a decent man
back okay
come on double tap
ya know the break so nice see we just
have to stay out of their reach hope to
dokie what's in that I like to think
that if they were alive they probably
want to help you nothing eats his brain
Squiggy Graham you still pretty sharp at
least we found something useful you
won't go another night without food okay
oh she's so nice to have some cute and a
waddle this must have been his kids toys
hmm nothing ever so creepy though
okay right yes maybe it's back by the
dog
what's in the looking here
her face well here we go
oh my god thank you look stubby look I
can
let's see what's inside
please don't be bad I can't even open
tins that well with a can open letter
tonight she is so talented
yes beans thank God
are you hungry I guess you are pretty
hungry too that is you here you go oh
hey I died because I was freaking out
way too much it's fact my concentrate
this time okay
hey are they making do it like that
I hope I never have to do that in my
entire life
painful
she's gonna die from blood loss will she
cry
where do they even come from a second to
go home with all clear what the hell
she's so brave to make them in time we
can do it run go so got my pen knife
that's good
oh my god is catching up see what
about crabber let's go come on kid we
got
here
I think I think we're safe
I hope yeah yeah we're good
hey you alright
um I think so I I think so
so finally you meet people that are nice
to little kids
oh very rare nowadays doing out here
where the people you're with there's no
chance you made it this long on your own
I don't want them thinking we're doing
anything but try to help you my friend
and I got attacked
hmm these folks mention what they were
after they might have just wanted food
and we were cooking some sort of puzzle
they attacked you for a weasel damn that
is the hope they didn't mention any
names right they weren't searching for
anybody
well I'm Luke this is Pete hey there hi
I'm Clementine it's nice to meet you
Clementine for now we're gonna take you
back to our group and we got a doctor
with us and you look like you could do
some ocean what what is it
calm your teeth
it was a dog I didn't see any dog
Clementine come on kid we just saw you
with those lurkers back there it was I
swear
swearing doesn't make something so no no
I'm telling you the truth please
Oh have you say no to those big-ass all
right
let's see hey watch yourself hey don't
look at me like that you're the one
that's been here okay
what a meanie see
is it uh select she says
well could be a dog hard to say so weird
this dog the one that did this what what
does that matter Pete series Floyd line
Oh what did I do that
so a dog runs up bites you and then just
disappear I'm just a dog in the force
one at my food what did you expect it to
stick around I don't know
Clementine
yes you telling us the truth no look
the eyes what you answer ah making wrong
decisions
Oh Oh God for me what look she didn't
even say anything she doesn't like
someone calling her a liar okay I've got
a good [ __ ] detector
that's why you Oh God the input what is
that don't really hot it's just somebody
got camera can I help me we can have
Carlos take a look at it first
Nick ain't gonna like this not with what
happened you don't have to remind me of
that boy right sorry sir
come on
Clementine are you feeling alright I'm
fine
did you not see the bite well you better
be fine cuz I ain't carrying you anymore
at that bite on your arm don't worry
okay so that's it for now guys as I
explained to you I've watched the first
and second episodes off and on but the
third and all the rest of this series I
don't know anything about so I'm really
looking forward to get into this because
I'm gonna be all like exactly the
storyline what I wanted to do from you
guys was do you want me to carry on I
know most of you will have seen this
before and that's perfectly fine if you
think that it's boring to see it again I
will just won't bother about it but I
will play it for myself like like a
little Larry so please let me know give
me a like if you want to see more give
me a comment if you don't want me to do
this then what games do you want me to
play I'd be interested in knowing
thank you again DX Dutch for this
wonderful birthday present and I'm gonna
have so much fun playing this have loved
it down evening bye I won case presents
cake